[Music]
miss you with all my heart
[Music]
Nick Carter remembers his late brother
Aaron
[Music]
he's always been that brother that's
been like a father figure that's been
like I'm gonna push you Nick's new song
hurts to love you pays tribute to Aaron
just over two months after the 34 year
old was found dead at home
[Music]
Nick gives fans a preview of the
upcoming music video on Instagram in the
Quick Clip he looks sad as home movies
of a young Aaron play out
[Music]
elsewhere in the song allusions to his
younger brother's personal struggles
always
hold you tomorrow
be better than the dance before
[Music]
what I need is people to
understand that I'm human
and I make mistakes just like every
other human in this world as Nick sees
it we all have someone in our lives that
no matter what they do and how bad it
hurts you still love them so I worked it
out the best way I know how they said
100 million
E.T witness Nick and Aaron's brotherly
Bond over the years well obviously
Aaron's not a career
and he's very talented and even though
their relationships soured near the end
of Aaron's life the love was always
there I'm used to people coming up to me
oh hi and it's mixed little brother how
you doing so you know it's kind of like
I said you know I get used to it but
Nick did get me started in this and I
thank him for that very much
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
could feel
[Music]